Hello I’m Daven Hiskey, you’re watching
the Today I Found Out YouTube channel.
In the video today, we’re looking at whether
fish ever get thirsty.
For fish, or at least teleost fish (which
make up about 96% of all fish), the desire
to drink is an urge that originates from the
hindbrain, whereas in land-based animals it
originates in the forebrain.
It is generally thought from this that a fish
has no real ability to consciously feel thirst
as we or many other land-animals would understand
it; for them, it's just a natural reflex.
So the short answer to whether fish ever get
thirsty is thought to be "no", at least not
on a conscious level.
However, fish do need to take in water, but,
as with land animals, too much water can kill,
a particular problem when one is surrounded
by it!
Unsurprisingly, the processes by which this
is regulated in fish is quite fascinating,
and further answers the question of why most
fish must stay in either a saltwater or freshwater
environment exclusively.
To begin with, we'll start with how exactly
fish drink.
Like any other animal, fish need to maintain
a strict balance of water and salt (among
other minerals) in their system to remain
alive and flipping along.
As they’re constantly surrounded by water,
the main issue for fish isn’t concerning
getting enough water in their bodies, but
regulating concentration of certain minerals,
of particular importance being things like
salt and potassium.
For freshwater fish, their blood has a higher
concentration of salt than their surroundings
(hypertonic), which is a major problem.
While their skin is mostly impermeable (though
not completely), as their gills are in constant
contact with the surrounding water, which
is essential for them to breathe, water is
continually taken into the fish' bloodstream
via osmosis, with osmotic pressure being the
key driver here.
For the uninitiated, osmosis is the movement
of a solvent (in this case water) across semi-permeable
membranes (like cell walls), from areas of
lower solute concentration to areas of higher
solute concentration.
This naturally equalizes the solute concentration
on both sides of the membrane.
(This osmotic pressure is also why salt can
be used to preserve meat.)
For example, if you take a red blood cell
and place it in distilled water, thanks to
osmotic pressure and the fact that the cell
membrane is thin and semipermeable, the cell
with its relatively salty interior next to
the pure water will gradually absorb more
and more water until it explodes.
On the flipside, if you place that same red
blood cell in water that is saltier than the
cell’s interior liquid, the reverse will
happen and the cell will gradually lose water,
shriveling up in the process.
Place it in water that has the same solute
level as the cell, and nothing at all will
happen.
(Certain sea-life, known as osmoconformers,
such as most marine invertebrates, actually
are more or less always in this state- maintaining
the same solute concentration internally as
the seawater they live in).
Thus, to regulate the large amount of water
entering its bloodstream diluting the concentration
of dissolved minerals, such as the ever important
salt, freshwater fish must urinate incredibly
often.
(This is one of the reasons it’s advised
to clean a goldfish bowl regularly or install
a filter.
And, note, contrary to popular practice, you
should never, ever leave a goldfish in a small,
simple fish bowl for a variety of reasons,
see our video on the matter for more information).
Towards this end, freshwater fish have large
kidneys with a relatively expansive network
of capillaries, called the glomerulus, facilitating
faster urine production.
This helps, but the fresh water fish also
need to take in relatively significant amounts
of salt to further aid in keeping their levels
high enough.
They are able to do this thanks to special
chloride secretory cells in their gills which
will actively draw salt from the surrounding
water and release it into the bloodstream,
at the same time osmotic pressure is drawing
more and more water into their system, diluting
the blood.
The problem for saltwater fish is more or
less the exact opposite as freshwater fish,
and it should come as no surprise then that
their drinking and urinating habits likewise
go the other way.
The saltwater fish have less salt in their
blood than the surrounding water (hypotonic).
So rather than absorbing water as it passes
through their gills, saltwater fish lose a
lot of water from their blood as they breathe
via the same osmotic pressure as mentioned
with the freshwater fish.
As a result, they must drink considerable
amounts of water through their mouths.
However, again, because the part of the brain
that controls this is in the hindbrain, it's
generally thought this regular swallowing
of water is a reflex action performed without
a conscious thirst sensation.
Saltwater fish also don't urinate much at
all, in order to conserve water.
Towards this end, they have very few, small
capillary networks making up their glomerulus,
unlike freshwater fish.
However, the water the saltwater fish are
drinking has an awful lot of salt in it- much
more than they need.
To get around this, the chloride secretory
cells of saltwater fish, rather than absorbing
salt from the surrounding water as with freshwater
fish, actively release it from the fish’s
body into the environment.
This all combines to more or less automatically
keep the saltwater fish's salt levels in the
optimal range.
As for fish that can migrate back and forth
from fresh water to seawater, their bodies
are capable of regulating both ways, but they
typically require an acclimation period between
the two.
For instance, salmon start their lives in
freshwater, and as they begin to transition
to saltwater they'll naturally start drinking
more and more water, while their urine production
begins to rapidly drop.
At the same time, a special enzyme results
in a reversal of the previous function of
their chloride secretory cells in their gills-
instead of absorbing salt from the environment,
the "pump" reverses, excreting it.
Once their bodies have fully transitioned
(generally after a few days hanging out in
the intertidal zone), they are free to safely
venture out into the big blue.
The same thing happens again in reverse when
they return to fresh water to spawn, spending
a few days acclimating in between until the
system has naturally switched and they can
safely head up stream.